I mean I think we actually invented the
movement we just take a moment real
quick for the queen of fashion Diane von
Furstenberg who is famous for her
incredible stunning beautiful wrap dress
and she has agreed to collaborate on a
project and make this custom dress and
my measurements were just insane and
make it out of describe fabrics from her
other dresses so fabrics that she
wouldn't have normally used therefore
putting it towards a purpose and
creating less waste and making a
sustainable dress that we now call
I had this idea that I think went before
to do is we should go down to the sample
room and pick up scrap all the scraps
that would make today normally thrown
away because it's an idea actually that
I was thinking of doing a scrap rap
[Music]
that's a huge step towards sustainable
fashion she's so open minded and willing
to make that move and I can tell she's
super excited about it as well and to be
able to collaborate with her is an
absolute honor I feel so blessed right
now and yeah this is a dream like I keep
saying is this real